we've been talking about sustainable
resources like food and energy and water
and now we need to bring these things
together and we bring them together
geographically and talk about where
people live so today where I'm going to
talk with you about sustainable cities
what do I mean by cities what are the
technical challenges to sustainability
in cities and there are a lot of them
the use of land and materials for
building transportation to get people
around the city and in contact with each
other energy water wastes air quality
the economy of the city is part of its
sustainability you could have a lot of
other things but if there's no
employment it's a little hard to argue
that the city's sustainable cultural
educational recreational health and
entertainment institutions it's not just
physical it's also attraction in New
York City right now is the place that
undergraduates in America want to study
why is it because they love NYU and
Columbia and Ford him and all the rest
and CUNY no is it because they all saw
friends when they were growing up and
they all want to be Jerry Seinfeld maybe
judging by the number of people standing
outside of Tom's restaurant taking
photos for a show that hasn't been on
the air in a decade it's it's pretty
interesting my brother's a professor at
NYU and his biggest complaint is the
number of tour buses that go through the
village on a regular basis and crowd the
small streets down there so these other
factors these intangibles of culture and
entertainment are incredibly important
then of course there are the financial
challenges we have to pay for these
things the organizational and management
challenges we have to figure out a way
for our organizations to work on this
then of course the public policies that
will encourage it so let me start with
the definition what's a city
well first the city is a place that's
not designed to be in harmony with
natural ecosystems but it's a place
dominated by human activities there's
the city in its the concept of the city
is actually to bring people together and
in a sense keep nature out that's why we
built cities in the first place to keep
nature out so it's a kind of interesting
concept when you think about
sustainability so what do I mean by
sustainability when I think about cities
well first a city that uses as few
non-renewable resources as possible and
then has the least possible damaging
impact on the rest of the environment so
it's part of the question here is how do
you bring all these people together
without destroying the planet by
minimizing the impact on the planet
now every society defines its
metropolitan urban areas in different
ways but it's always about population in
the United States we say that an urban
area with 50,000 or more in population
or an area with 50,000 or more in
population is an urban area but think
about what that means okay I mean what
it really means is in the United States
Phoenix is a city right anybody here
from Phoenix okay so that's a city and
New York is a city now these are very
different places in the physical
geography of the cities are different
their relationship to their surrounding
ecosystems is different and yet there
are all cities by the way we're defining
them there are now over 3.7 billion
people living in the world's urban areas
and urban areas can vary from very small
towns like White Plains or Jersey City
or Trenton these are fairly small places
too mega cities places like Bogota or
Mexico City or Tokyo or Hong Kong you go
to a place like Hong
and the scale that is even impressive -
somebody's from New York you know I'm
used to seeing six apartment buildings
together and develop them in each of
them going 30 storeys high there they're
sixteen and they're all going 70 storeys
high
it's the scale of those cities is almost
dwarfing the cities that we're used to
cities are concentration of humans and
their activities and what is the
concentration do it provides both
opportunities for cost effective
infrastructure and problems due to the
impact of these concentrations of people
on the planet now the alternative if you
were to spread everybody out among the
planet that has other impacts then we
try that here in America we called it
New Jersey we actually call the suburban
sprawl we the the places in New Jersey
that that were in the countryside or the
places in Long Island that used to be
potato farms are now considered by
census definition as part of cities when
we think of em as suburbs but they're
really cities they have sewer systems
and and electrical utilities and all of
the things that cities have including
taxes and school systems and all those
other municipal services they are they
are cities we have to be thinking now
about what kind of geographic layout
creates the most sustainable type of
city now sprawl which was how we got
started on a lot of our expansion in
America of urban areas creates its own
problems non-point sources of pollution
meaning pollution that doesn't come from
a pipe but pollution that comes from
runoff from roads and from gardens and
from farms is one of the problems
ecosystem destruction as well
inefficient infrastructure when you have
those lower densities it's more
expensive you got to run that sewer line
another 30 yards but there's only four
people at the end of it that is
expensive
you know because the there's fewer
shared resources I mean the general
design of New York City is very energy
efficient because as Paul Simon said in
a song you know one man's ceiling is
another man's floor when you have when
you live in an apartment you have less
heat escape less air conditioning
problems less exterior walls and less
physical space we live in this city on
much less space per person than people
do in Phoenix or in Tucson or in Los
Angeles where we're used to smaller
places and part of it is because we
actually spend less time in those places
because we spend more time in public
spaces it's part of what attracts people
to New York City it's part of why all
these kids want to go to college here
because they don't want to stay home and
watch the big screen TV with the family
all night long every night night after
night after night you know they were to
go out and do something you know believe
it or not so there's that much of the
u.s. is projected population growth for
the 21st century though could be
accommodated by going back to the old
cities if you go to anybody here been to
Newark recently there are open fields in
Newark New Jersey right now okay there
are apartment there are opportunities
for real estate development in downtown
North you can't find anywhere else in
New Jersey you know except in Lancet
that you're not allowed to build on
because they're ecologically fragile and
it's sitting on top of all that urban
infrastructure it's already there ok so
and that's true in Detroit and that's
true in Cleveland and that's true all
over the place and so that's an
advantage the United States has China
doesn't have that and Africa doesn't
have that they're gonna have to build
new cities in those places now there has
some advantages actually if they build
them correctly but much of the world new
cities and settlements are going to have
to be built so there's a need to develop
all of these with the least possible
environmental impact and that requires a
great care in designing human settlement
where we reduce the
flow of resources in and pollution out
that's really what has to happen and
that is a design question we actually
can do more development more population
density in some cases than we have with
lower impacts if we manage it correctly
now one of the classic works in this
which I didn't ask you to read for this
course but which you might want to read
was written in 1969 by a fellow named
Ian McHarg he wrote a book called design
with nature and it was one of the more
influential books of its time in
thinking about urban sprawl suburban
sprawl actually that book and Jane
Jacobs the death and life of great
American cities were two of the most
important books I think that have ever
been written in terms of understanding
how to make sustainable cities Jacobs
argued against large-scale mega projects
and and understood the fabric of cities
and the street life and how important it
was and the Karg actually paid a lot of
attention to drainage one of the things
that he said which is which you see
reflected in what's called cluster
development is if you take a piece of
property instead of subdividing it and
and putting you know a hundred houses on
one acre plots if you put the hundred
houses on five acres and save the other
ninety five acres as open space you can
create common space for all the people
living in those five acres and in fact
increase their quality of life and
maintain the eco the ecosystems at the
same time and you discover something
that's pretty interesting that I don't
think everybody understood everybody
likes that acre around them for
psychological purposes but they actually
did studies and showed that ninety
percent of the utilization of the
acreage was in the part right adjacent
to the house called the patio that most
of the that most people's outdoor access
in their suburban homes does not take
place on the borderline of their
property but in fact takes place right
next to the house and that in fact you
could that if you develop these houses
with enough soundproofing and enough
privacy and so forth they would be very
popular and they are they have they've
worked although people still
the same time the following this his
work you also see the development of
cluster housing and the mega mansion
okay you see the you know people
building these five six seven eight
thousand square feet homes you know and
again nobody lives in five six seven
eight thousand square feet you know even
Derek Jeter
you know you don't need that much space
no matter and you could have a family of
forty you probably don't need that much
space and most people are there by
themselves with their one or two kids
and so do you really need your own
bowling alley and your own home theater
and six-car garage somebody does okay
okay well so there there are some people
who think this is an essential for their
quality of life but I'm skeptical about
it but by concentrating human
settlements and by managing our waste
flows and where the water runs off of
our settlements we can probably
accommodate the other three million
people we're going to get three billion
people are going to get before the
population of the planets stabilizes
well-designed land use can reduce stress
on ecological systems by managing where
you put people you don't put people
number on the marshes in the most
fragile environments you don't drain
them to build subdivisions you find the
Highlands you put the buildings there
you put the buildings in places where
they will minimize impact and you build
drainage around it to collect the human
impact so that they don't destroy the
local ecosystems and you try to think
about what's our ecological footprint as
we build so this is of course what you
need to do but to do this the free
market and land use in sales has to be
regulated because otherwise you know
there are a lot of people that need the
bowling alley in the and the private
viewing screen and the bar and the
cappuccino cart that's only for them and
all the rest of that whatever it is that
they seem to need all this space and no
you know it's it's kind of an
interesting thing if you if you think
about how people live I'm
it's not to say people want a 200 square
foot efficiency you know there is
certainly a certain amount of physical
space people need but the average home
in the United States it keeps going
larger and larger and larger it's
actually that's changed recently because
of the recession but before the
recession it was just going up and up
and up and you know that's all space
you've got a heat or air condition it's
all space you've got a you know that is
not really necessary for many people's
quality of life and in any event in a
planet with ten billion people we have
to think about the resources that we use
the land use of materials is a challenge
a lot of builders and architects are
paying serious attention to the
sustainability of their building systems
and materials and we're seeing more and
more attention being paid to that in our
own masters program we have a course in
that architects in the architecture
school here are paying more and more
attention to these issues of building
materials and I think that we're going
to see more of that as time goes on
however it's not just the construction
it's the maintenance one of the issues
that's coming up with LEED certification
is they find yes when they get certified
efforts built it has this level of
energy efficiency but like everything
else if you don't perform correct
operation maintenance on it pretty soon
it's it's loses its ability to save
energy and so we have to be thinking
about that issue now let's turn to
transportation why do we have so many
cars in America we have 260 million
autos I think what is it about 330
million people and almost as many autos
as we have people you know you go to
suburban communities and people have
three four or five cars you know all the
teenagers have cars and the adults have
cars and they don't share the cars is
you know and they're all driving you
know you go their debt the daily life of
many Americans involves hours a day in
the automobile you know they're on the
telephone and the automobile okay if
they could be they'd be on the Internet
in the automobile many
Mr and it's making the automobile less
safe but the fundamental is that they're
in traffic for hours on end you go to
Los Angeles and you you want to go out
to dinner with your friends you know
it's it's a 45-minute ride each way
easily to go anywhere okay and that's
become the way people live throughout
America it's it's really kind of
astonishing when you think about it and
I think people are getting a little
tired of it at least some people are
getting tired of it which is accounting
for people moving out of some
subdivisions and of course the great
danger here in New York City is when all
these people from New Jersey show up and
try to make right turn on red you know
and there's there's these people that
cross the street they call them
pedestrians here and if you've seen them
but New Jersey they apparently don't
have them because these guys you know
they're they're out there gunning for
you you know it's it's not just the
right turn right it's this idea of
yielding to a pedestrian you know that
if somebody's in the crosswalk the car
is supposed to stop not the people it
really seems almost alien to the culture
but in fact we're seeing more and more
people paying attention to these kinds
of issues and thinking about about the
automobile but what happened here to be
serious for a moment is whenever people
say well government can't spend money on
infrastructure because it's anti
capitalism who do you think built the
roads and what Rose did they built and
why did they build them the interstate
highway system was built now the they
were actually called the National
Defense highway system when Eisenhower
proposed him and the real reason was to
have tanks be able to go from base to
base and from one part of the country to
the to the next in fact the real use of
it like most military infrastructure
ended up being to facilitate the
development of the American suburbs and
and then we discovered something you
know you build a two-lane interstate it
got after a certain amount of time the
real estate in the outer areas gets
filled up and then the roads get filled
up so you build a three lane it takes a
little less time they go a little
further till it gets clogged up and then
you build a four-link and transportation
planners would tell
there's no end to this and it's what
happens is if I reduce the amount of
time from my job to the place I'm living
then it makes the land a little further
cheaper so I go out there and I build
and then I build and I build so in the
earth is that we have the lamont-doherty
Earth Observatory exit for the Palisades
Parkway land out there used to be pretty
cheap for people to buy homes the
scientists all lived around there and
relatively inexpensive homes now the
homes there are more expensive than than
some of them are and within New York
City and part of the reason for that is
that it got faster to commute up there
by car and people you know and that was
all subsidized all that transportation
was subsidized so with the exception of
New York City Americans travel more by
order than by any other means and that
makes them unique in the world Americans
are in their autos and and that is a
problem for sustainability in the long
run that we will eventually go to less
polluting cars but the infrastructure
that we've built the sprawl pattern of
development we're kind of stuck with and
I think what you're going to see is more
and more town like settings out in the
suburbs you're going to see more and
more in a sense that's how New York City
developed when you think about you know
the parts the part of Brooklyn I'm from
it builds up around a subway stop I mean
it was basically the countryside the
subway stop gets bill suddenly right by
the subway you see higher density
apartment buildings and a commercial
strip New York City is built that way
New York City is a collection of
neighborhoods in that sense and you're I
think you're going to start seeing more
and more of this in suburban areas maybe
with mass transit connections leading to
them if the government decides to invest
the money in it one problem with sprawl
development is that once it takes place
the land needed for subways becomes too
expensive and we actually see a graphic
case study of this in Bogota Colombia
where the sprawl took place first
I mean Bogota just like Los Angeles
developed out without mass transit with
single
family homes and apartment buildings but
connected by the automobile so what they
did which was kind of brilliant is they
built something called the Red Line bus
system a north-south and east-west
dedicated bus line which uses trolley
like train stations so they have real
train stations and they'll attach six or
seven buses together and what they do is
they have time traffic lights and they
ride on the surface and it's the fastest
way of getting around town I can tell
you've had the experience of being in a
taxicab next to one of these things
we're stuck in gridlock and the buses
zooming along and they built it for 300
million dollars in the cost of building
the subway there would have been four to
five billion dollars so there are
potential solutions personal
transportation has to become more
sustainable we absolutely have to figure
out a way to make a car that runs on
something besides gasoline and I think
we're be seeing the beginnings of that
happening now another technical
challenge is energy urban energy systems
rely on centralized fossil fuel based
power plants and power transmission
lines that are owned by government
regulated monopolies the cities provide
concentrations of customers so a company
like Canada sand can be profitable
because there's so many customers along
the lawn so they invest in the
infrastructure and there's lots of
revenue because lots of people using the
the power there now one possibility with
the development of smart grids would be
a distributed power generation where in
fact people can generate power in their
own homes and their own apartments even
and when they're not using it send it
back to the grid we don't have the
technology we have the technology to do
it it's not been widely spread yet but
that is clearly part of the of the
technical of the infrastructure the
energy infrastructure of the future of
course as we learned earlier with
sea-level rise it all get ruined during
the floods but hopefully we'll figure
out a way to deal with that too but
cities are built on energy they require
not just plentiful but reliable energy
if you live in a developing country city
and the power goes out
or the power goes out for certain hours
of the day sometimes or goes out for
days on end you can't really build an
economy when you have that lack of
reliability and so you need reliable
energy but it has to be delivered to the
lowest possible cost and with the least
possible environmental impacts energy
systems are often over designed to
prevent these failures but those over
designs can be wasteful so one of the
places where information technology can
in fact help us and this is really where
the smart grid comes in is you can build
a system with less redundancy and less
waste
if you have the kinds of control system
that allows for you to not have to have
essentially mechanical redundancy on
redundancy on redundancy one of the
problems with that is that those kinds
of systems can still be very vulnerable
now I may be being a little too abstract
here but if you think about last year we
should Segoe the Long Island Railroad
switching station in Jamaica got hit by
a lick by a lightning and it knocked out
the facility which was an old-style
electrical switching facility
fortunately the the people who worked
there knew how to mechanically go out
onto the tracks with you know pieces of
equipment and move the tracks physically
okay that was their redundancy now you
could imagine a higher tech electronic
system where we might forget how to do
this physical switchover of the of the
tracks you know we've one of the fears
that New Yorkers have in their subway is
if we had a DC style Metro without
conductors inside the the trains that
could actually run the train you know
who knows what might happen and so there
are those kinds of issues but the the
technological fix of more elaborate
computer controls and more sophisticated
control systems with electronic
then physical backups are possible
another technological challenge is water
and sewage treatment ever we talked
about these issues before but
sustainable sources of fresh water have
to have the capacity to be resupplied
with clean fresh water geologic sources
of water can't be relied on because they
will run out one of the issues that I've
written about recently is the issue of
hydro fracking which is you know
injecting liquids into the stone
structure beneath the the beneath the
the ecosystems essentially to get at
natural gas the problem is if in the
process of doing that you have an
explosion you have damage from the the
liquids that you're pumping in you could
contaminate your underground sources of
water and the water supply system that
New York City relies on comes from an
area that's also rich in natural gas and
so the here we see the direct trade-off
between cheap and even potentially low
carbon energy and our source of water
supply now the source of water supply
frankly is more valuable because there's
other ways of dealing with the energy
issue but water's water and geographies
geography so we'll see unless natural
ecosystems filter water supply
artificial water filtration system has
to be constructed to maintain they cost
a lot of money they use a lot of energy
you know I think I talked about this in
this class but in New York City if we
didn't have the filtration avoidance
agreement for the water that's on the
west side of the Hudson we would have to
build a six billion dollar filtration
plant which would cost us probably a
half a billion dollars a year in
interest payments and operation
maintenance to run
that's versus the two to three hundred
million a year now we pay the farmers
and the other folks up by our water
supply to use best management practices
and to steadily buy the land
surrounding the watershed to protect it
but all it would take is one Gulf of
Mexico style disaster as you're trying
to mine for gas and all that investment
goes out the window including the five
billion dollar water tunnel we've been
building since 1970
so part of the question here is can we
be smart enough not to try to take risks
that aren't sustainable and we'll see
whether New York State is smart enough
over the next several years now once
water has been used it becomes a waste
product when combined with storm water
fresh water has to be treated and
cleaned before it's returned to the
waterways eventually that's the same
water you're going to drink in other
words the hydrological system is a
closed system okay so you want to try to
make sure that when you grab that sewage
you send it back into the water as much
like water as you can and separate all
the impurities and treat it in some
other fashion this is an energy
intensive process so again we see water
and ecosystem protection and energy all
these systems are interconnecting at
cities and a sewage system that stops
functioning like a waste system of
garbage system stops functioning we
create a public health emergency in a
nanosecond the first sewage treatment
systems were built in part because of
cholera and in in London they discovered
it was human waste that was causing it
which led to the development of modern
sewage we must have those kinds of
systems functioning in our cities so
then we have the this next technical
challenge which is solid and toxic waste
management every person the United
States now generates four not five
pounds of solid waste we used to
generate 2.6 eight pounds in 1960 but
we've gone up a couple of pounds of
garbage in the last 50 years the three
hundred four million people or so live
in the United States generate 1.3
billion pounds of waste each day waste
per cap
peaked at 4.6 five pounds in two
thousand now going down so this four
point five number is actually lower than
it was a decade ago now that actually
gives me some hope that we may have
peaked and in fact a lot of garbage you
know in nineteen sixty almost all that
2.6 pounds was tossed into landfills now
about half of the garbage is recycled or
is used in waste to energy plants to
generate energy and so we are recovering
and burning more and more of our garbage
in that and again so that technology
curve is on the up and that's also a
hopeful sign we're getting better at
recycling and reusing materials in
nineteen sixty ninety four percent of
the waste that we disposed of per capita
ended up in landfills or non energy
producing incinerators in two thousand
eight fifty four percent or two point
four pounds of every four point five
pounds we disposed of was dumped so
we're reducing the percentage of garbage
were dumped it okay this is a good thing
we have a long way to go and of course
the other problem is we're creating more
garbage per capita so it's the they keep
the finish line keeps moving but this is
an important place for us to understand
the technology is changing closing a
loop on waste disposal is an essential
element of a sustainable system of
material flow what we want to do is
everything we use in a city we want to
recycle or we want to use as an energy
source in some fashion that's really the
long-term goal there's an organization
in California called zero waste that
thinks that we could actually get down
to having nothing thrown out in the end
I don't know if we can get that for but
we get a lot closer to zero that 1.3
billion patents a day I think we can
probably do that the local economy and
culture influences the content of waste
of and the best possible waste
management options and there's a city
like New York has a different waste
management problem in the city like
Indianapolis
Indianapolis burns all of its garbage in
a waste-to-energy plant in New York City
we hope some point will develop marine
transfer facilities so it can at least
ship the garbage out instead of driving
it out of town in diesel trucks but we
need to work on the waste management
part of our technical equation landfills
are often the least expensive option for
many places but every landfill
eventually leaks I think eventually
we're going to get better and better at
this as resources become more expensive
the economy for recycling becomes that
much more valuable and I think we're
going to see more and more of that as
time goes on I think some of that will
just be a function of better technology
hopefully lower cost energy and an
ability to think through what we're
doing and also frankly the the cost of
land filling in the northeast of the
United States is getting higher and
higher and eventually we're going to
we'll be like Japan where over 70% of
their garbage is burnt for energy and I
think we're going to see stuff like that
happen with the in Europe it's already
happening and certainly in the Northeast
here the toxicity of the waste stream
and the presence of abandoned toxic
waste sites are key technical challenges
to urban sustainability and here the
issue of electronic waste is
particularly important we have to figure
out a way to reduce the toxicity of the
waste stream through recycling through
reuse and through separate sorting
systems for garbage I mean the fact is
in this room
usually three garbage cans 20 years from
now there'll be six in every room you'll
see more and more sorting because if you
can sort at the beginning it really
improves the technology going through
although the other thing that might
happen is we might end up with fewer
garbage cans and better sorting machines
centrally but a lot of that will depend
on the energy toxic substances can be
difficult to recycle and can contaminate
otherwise non toxic and valuable
substances in the waste stream
so part of the issue is trying to make
sure that when we get rid of our our
garbage that we do it in a way that
doesn't contact doesn't contaminate the
good garbage in the sense it's like a
compost pile or an anaerobic digester
which is a NOLA which is a mechanical
version of that if the stuff going into
the wet garbage stream has toxic sin it
then when we use the product of that
anaerobic digester as fertilizer it will
have toxics in it and it won't be usable
and so we need to figure out ways of
reducing the toxicity of our production
processes and it's trying to reduce the
amount of toxic sin these electronics to
begin with but then to make sure that we
separate it when we dispose of it now
there are a number of strategies now in
place for dealing with toxic waste
because we don't know how to technically
detoxify waste so the way we manage
toxic waste now is we try to make sure
people are not in the pathways of
exposure which is really what we did in
the 80s and Superfund over 50 million
people in America were in pathways of
exposure in 1980 when Superfund passed
by 1990 virtually nobody was is a major
environmental success story that nobody
talks about the other thing we do is we
use water and filtration systems to
gradually dilute a site and to move its
toxic sout and the other thing we do is
dig it up and segregate it none of those
involve detoxifying really we don't
really know how to take toxic substances
and make them non toxic but someday
we'll need to do that now let me talk a
little bit about another technical
challenge which is air quality some of
the sources of air pollution are local
but a lot of it comes from other places
you can do things locally to reduce the
impact of air pollution how you design
your transportation systems how you
segregate residences the amount of trees
you plant all of that can vary and local
conditions make a difference we happen
to be in a city that has a lot of wind
that goes from west to east and so when
we don't have the kind of inversions
here that you see in Los Angeles which
which means we can actually take a
heavier load
of pollutants then some places can non
fossil fuels and energy conservation can
reduce the environmental impact of
electric power generation and so there
are things we can do technically to
reduce air pollution but air pollution
remains a technical challenge of
urbanization
then there's the issues of quality of
life which I mentioned at the very
beginning cities have to be attractive
and exciting places to live and we know
we can build cities to be less
environmentally destructive than other
places but we need to have amenities and
employment that attract people that's
part of sustainability in cities museums
university systems nightclubs good
restaurants all of those things are part
of what makes an urban area attractive
and therefore sustainable ok there are
financial challenges that I should
mention which is to say that we're going
to need a lot of new infrastructure to
do some of these things electric car
charging station smart grids renewable
energy the problem in the United States
and certainly anybody watching the
election last night wouldn't get this
idea but we're undertaxed
now I'm not running for Congress so I
can say that but in fact we are under
taxed and we don't save enough and we're
not building enough for the future in
this country and that's that's a very
large problem and a lot of the
infrastructure we build we borrow for so
we're basically saddling the next
generation with many of the costs of
that infrastructure so we need to
increase the savings rate now
fortunately the Great Recession has done
some of that our savings rate was
actually below zero during the height of
the grid of the boom of the Bush years
and is now gradually getting up to about
four percent historically in America the
savings rate vary between six and ten
percent and that's that's a society
that's deferring gratification for the
future what we did during the 90s in
particular and during the the first part
of the 21st century is we would take the
wealth out of our homes take out second
mortgages buy big-screen TVs and extra
car
you know I mean literally that's how
America lived that party's over people
aren't doing that anymore and in place
they're putting away money for a rainy
day that creates the potential capital
for investment in this infrastructure so
the but that still remains a financial
challenge the transition to a green
economy is going to require massive
investments in public infrastructure
just as we built the interstate highway
system we're gonna have to build a new
system of energy generation and
distribution where sustainability
investments can save money creative
forms of municipal finance can transform
the future savings into capital for
immediate investments in other words if
I know that by doing something I can
save twenty percent of my energy costs I
can use those reductions in my monthly
bills to finance that infrastructure and
we're seeing the beginnings of some of
those techniques going on now but that's
not always feasible and sometimes the
the people that have to build the
infrastructure are not the same people
who are gonna benefit from those
investments part of what's going on also
is that some of these systems are
getting more complicated and cost more
so water is probably the best example
the price of water used to be hidden in
your property taxes now it's become a
separate charge that you pay in addition
to your property taxes and the reason
for that is that the cost of water is
gonna filtrations gotten more expensive
sewage treatment gotten more expensive
and transmission has gotten more
expensive and so we're paying more for
now I think people can handle the idea I
remember when television was free you
just put up your antenna and it came to
you and now my television bill is over a
hundred dollars a month okay and so
water is working the same way urban
amenities that promote sustainability
are going to carry charges of the urban
amenity of driving a car in lower
Manhattan will eventually require a
separate charge and I think other fees
are coming because we're going to have
to figure out ways of funding
this infrastructure because we're just
going to need to do it sustainable
cities will require capital from a
variety of sources
they'll be debt retired by increased
taxes they'll be savings that are
generated they'll be private investment
you see this with I think it's Google is
talking about getting into the wind a
transmission business in the Atlantic
but I will say this if we keep starving
our infrastructure investment in this
country then the future wealth of the
country will be significantly impaired
we simply have to build for the future
now we've always done this in this
country but lately we stopped we stopped
I mean in New York City we stopped
investing in the subway system for a
decade and the system almost collapsed
so we had to spend all of the 1980s
rebuilding the subway system in a sense
a lot of the critical infrastructure the
roads the waterways the electrical
transmission lines in America our need
the same kind of replenishment that we
applied to the city subway system during
the 80s this creates organizational and
management challenges local government
is where a lot of this action is going
to be and the corporate world is where a
lot of these changes are going to take
place we need organizations to have the
capacity to think routinely about how do
we reduce material and energy resources
how do we reduce the amount of waste
that we're generating these have to
become the standard operating procedures
of the new management and frankly this
is why I say over and over again that
that in the next decade all effective
management is going to have to be
sustainability management we simply have
no choice but to add this to the
equation and just as financial
accounting became part of how
organizations were managed in the 30s
40s and 50s information management comes
in in the 60s 70s and 80s the physical
dimensions of sustainability will be
entering into routine management over
the next 10 20 and 30 years because
these parameters are going to become
part of how a company develops a
profitable edge and will be expected by
investors and
affected by taxpayers you know the if
you waste energy and water in your
operation people are gonna wonder what
were you thinking of why are you it will
be just like wasting money on labor and
equipment that you don't use and I think
that's going to become part of how we
think about management in the future now
for this to happen
government has to play a role the market
alone is not going to do this the market
has never done these kinds of things
alone it's always required government
government built the interstate highway
systems built the American farm system
it was deeply involved in the generation
of power in rural areas the Tennessee
Valley Authority transformed the middle
of this country or there wouldn't have
been power in those places because it
wasn't anybody's financial interests to
bring power to rural areas all of that
was government intervention so
government has to encourage set
boundaries and educate in the end it's
got a it's going to result in I hope a
public policy environment that's more
conducive to this and entrepreneurship
in the private sector that's focused on
these sustainability issues now anybody
who watched the elections last night is
thinking boy we're a long way from that
I'm actually writing something about
that I started it today because in fact
most of the environmental plebiscites
that were on the ballot yesterday passed
the most important one was in California
Proposition 23 which passed dramatically
proposition 23 was an effort to repeal
California's climate and energy laws and
one of the main constituencies for
retaining that were the entrepreneurs in
Silicon Valley that are trying to move
from the computer-based innovation
they've been doing in the past to
renewable energy and other kinds of
sustainability investments and they were
out there pushing for this and all over
the United States those I think it was
at least 80% of the environmental ballot
issues passed and people mistrust the
institutions they're scared about the
economy they're scared about the future
and they've clearly lost confidence in
the Democrats and in the president but
there
not thinking that you can get around the
constraints of the physical environment
and they're not willing to sacrifice the
environment so I think we're going to
see more and more of this but government
has to get involved in it and
unfortunately the mantra of the moment
the the folks that just took over the
House of Representatives keep referring
to this as job-killing environmental
jobs that is complete and utter nonsense
okay it's nonsense in economic terms
it's simply wrong you know the jobs of
the future
require these investments you know
because and if they don't invest it here
you know I guess we should all learn
Mandarin because in China they're
figuring this out in a hurry maybe not
as quickly as they think or we'd like to
think but believe me America is not
alone in the global economy and if we
don't take on the these investments we
are going to be in trouble now this idea
that regulation is somehow anti-freedom
needs to be we need to move away from
that you know we regulated the car you
know when Ralph Nader got started he
wrote a book called unsafe at any speed
and he talked about the American
automobile and the American automobile
when he got started on this had no
seatbelts had no airbags had no cash
crash protection of any kind and the
automobile now is exponentially more
safer than it was before he started and
nobody thinks that you destroyed the
automobile industry by regulating the
safety of automobiles and that and
that's the point here you know in order
for us to live safely and sustainably on
this planet we simply have to figure out
a way to create a system of rules that
allow us to have 10 billion people on
this planet and have all of the high
quality of life that we have today you
know everybody has to be raised up to an
income level to enjoy the things that
you enjoy here and that I enjoy and
government has to be involved in that
because it's not going to happen through
the marketplace alone so that's
basically what I wanted to say about
sustained
the city's the answer to the dilemma of
sustainability is only going to be found
in the world cities this idea that we're
going to have to get back to the land
and harmony with nature you've heard me
say it before I'll say it again there's
too many of us and is not enough planet
for that so the answers we have to live
in cities and reduce our carbon and
ecological footprint manage our waste
and learn how to live in these kinds of
spaces I believe we can do it and
hopefully we will